[Music]
dna is the ultimate method of biological
information storage
it contains a full genetic instruction
manual for creating life from eye color
to height to the probability of getting
certain diseases it's the reason that
traits are passed down through
generations
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream and in
this episode of perspectives four
experts explain what dna is how we
discovered it and how it makes you you
we begin with an overview of dna and how
we inherit traits from our ancestors
[Music]
bacteria make more bacteria kangaroos
make more kangaroos and dandelions send
their fluffy seeds wafting gracefully on
the wind to make many more dandelions
but what is it in the seeds that can do
that and how come they always give rise
to dandelions and not ever even once to
dalmatians or ducks
the answer to those questions lies in
deoxyribonucleic acid or dna
this nucleic acid molecule carried in
the seeds has the complete instructions
for making dandelions which happen to be
different from the information for
making any other species
well in the nucleic acid that is dna we
have
a single molecule
with all the information for making all
the proteins
in each of the trillions of the body's
cells
when you think about what this really
means it boggles the mind
one molecule determines that a child has
grandpa's nose mom's musical talent and
great-grandmother's distinctive
cheekbones
on its way to you and me
our dna has passed through each
generation of our ancestors
in each generation the dna of two
individuals mingled to create unique
combinations carried by their children
the fertilized egg that gives rise to
each individual contains this dna which
is copied each time a cell divides with
a copy of the information passed on to
every one of the trillions of cells in a
human baby
deoxyribonucleic acid is a substance a
chemical you can get dna stuck to your
fingers
it appears inside our cells and this
sticky stuff was first discovered by a
biochemist named friedrich miesha
in the late 1860s his boss assigned him
the task of studying white blood cells
misha specifically chose to focus on the
nucleus of the white blood cells at a
time when the function of a cell nucleus
was unknown
to get white blood cells miesha had to
visit a local hospital each day
there he picked up their used pus soaked
bandages since pus is swimming with
white blood cells
no one ever said science had to be
glamorous
and to see what chemicals were in the
nucleus of the white blood cells misha
ran some chemical tests
one test involved washing the pus in
warm alcohol then rinsing it in an acid
from a pig's stomach
this dissolved away the cell membranes
and allowed him to isolate a gray paste
misha assumed this paste was a protein
so he ran some tests to identify it but
the paste didn't behave like a protein
would it wouldn't dissolve in salt water
or boiling vinegar or even in dilute
hydrochloric acid
his paste also contained phosphorus an
element that proteins lack
convinced he'd found something new and
unique in the nucleus of those cells
miesha named the substance nuclei
and his discovery contained what we now
call dna
it was a russian researcher by the name
of phoebus levine who started scientists
on the long road to understanding the
structure of this critical material that
mesher had discovered
levine was able to break the so-called
nuclean down into its constituent parts
he found phosphates
four organic bases adenine thymine
cytosine and guanine
and interestingly a sugar called ribose
in 1940 nearly 70 years after missus
discovery of nuclear
erwin chargaff made a telling
observation
he noticed that when he isolated all
four of the bases found by levine
cytosine and guanine were always present
in equal amounts
as were adenine and thymine
it was an intriguing observation and one
that hinted at the structure of dna
tantalizing as this observation was
debate still raged about exactly what
dna was and how the molecule was put
together
the world would have to wait another
decade to settle this argument
the key piece of data that unlocked the
secrets of this biopolymer was one from
the same technique that had proven
herman stoutinger write about cellulose
x-ray crystallography
the lab of maurice wilkins and rosalind
franklin at king's college in london as
well as that of james watson and francis
crick
generated that x-ray crystallography
data almost concurrently
a race to press ensued and watson and
crick prevailed securing their place in
history as the widely credited
discoverers of this
the dna double helix
the structure we are most familiar with
is a molecule that looks a bit like a
rope ladder twisted on itself
two sides of the ladder serve as
backbones of individual dna strands
separating the strands we discover that
each strand is a long polymer
the repeating subunits comprising the
polymer are called nucleotides
each nucleotide is made up of three
components a five-carbon sugar
a nitrogen-containing part called a base
and one or more phosphates
without phosphate the resulting molecule
is called a nucleoside
nucleotides that dna is built from are
called
deoxyribonucleoside triphosphates or
dntps
deoxyribose the sugar in dna nucleotides
has five carbons designated
one prime two prime three prime
four prime and five prime
why the prime that's because the base in
a nucleotide which has its own carbons
is also numbered one two three etc the
prime indicates we're talking about the
sugar's carbons
the sugar in dna would be ribose except
that its two prime carbon lacks the
oxygen and has only a hydrogen atom
attached so we call this sugar
deoxyribose or two prime deoxyribose
each nucleotide for building dna brings
energy to the job in the form of three
phosphates attached to the carbon at the
five prime position
also attached to the deoxyribose sugar
is a structure called a base
there are four different bases in dna
nucleotides adenine guanine cytosine and
thymine abbreviated a g
c and t
the related molecule called rna has the
same bases except that uracil u
substitutes for thymine
a double helix contains two such dna
strands oriented in opposite or
anti-parallel directions with the five
prime end of one strand across from the
three prime end of the other
bases in the two strands are oriented
such that the a's and t's always face
each other
and g's and c's are always across from
each other as well
the pairs of bases then form what look
like the rungs of a ladder inside of a
dna helix
with sugar phosphate backbones forming
the sides
the latter twists on itself resembling a
spiral staircase
why do bases pair as they do and never
switch partners
it's because the hydrogen bonds between
the bases only properly align when g is
adjacent to c and when a is adjacent to
t
the a's and t's share two hydrogen bonds
while g's and c's have three hydrogen
bonds between them
since a pairs with t and g pairs with c
it means that if we know the order or
sequence of bases in one strand
we can figure out the sequence of bases
on the partner strand
it is in the order or sequence of these
bases a g t and c that information is
encoded
now what kind of information exactly
well one major function of the
information and dna is to provide
instructions for making proteins
proteins are built from amino acids as
you've learned
but how do cells know the order to
string the amino acids together to make
each protein
it turns out that the information for
amino acids arises directly from the
sequence of bases in dna
so the sequence of bases in dna stores
information for making proteins
darwin recognized that his theory meant
that all organisms could trace their
history back to common ancestors
any two species no matter how different
share a common ancestor if you go back
far enough in time
he suggested that the history of
evolution can be thought of as a great
tree of life in which all the branches
are connected
the availability of dna sequence data
had two major impacts on efforts to
reconstruct the tree of life
first it meant that far more data were
available
the position of every dna base in the
genome like the first dna letter for a
particular gene or the 175th position
for a particular gene
could be considered a trait in a
phylogenetic analysis much like the
presence or absence of mammary glands
because the genomes of many organisms
are measured in megabases with one
megabase equal to 1 million dna bases
using genome sequences provides millions
of traits to study each organism
a lot more data for reconstructing the
tree of life
moreover biologists also developed ways
to use all this data in more
sophisticated ways
the only way for the dna in an
organism's genome to change from one
base like an a to another like a c
is through a mutation
and biologists have been able to work
out how often these mutations occur on
average in different groups of organisms
as elegant and remarkable as all of
these features of dna are
what really makes this molecule of life
useful is the fact that it is a polymer
dna strands can reach truly staggering
lengths in higher organisms and you are
a perfect example
the snippets of dna that i've been
showing you pale in comparison to the
size of your actual dna sequence
the human genome as it's called
consists of some 5 billion base pairs
strung together
that's enough dna to create a 1.8 meter
strand when extended completely nearly
as tall as i am
this makes dna the undisputed king of
information storage
five billion letters go into the code
that defines who you are at least in a
biochemical sense
[Music]
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here